I'm here John I'm mucuna under a tree in
the waffle research my topic is about
geometric modeling this is about how to
build it easily quickly build the 2d or
3d models by the Wolfram language
building functionalities so here is the
outline of my talk so the Wolfram
language actually provides several ways
to help the user to build their models
very easily so we'll wait you the water
language has its own database so it
allow user to access a lot of large
number of geometry models it also
provided a search function to allow user
to access the outside the online
repository life the inward light Anagha
so the user can import the models
download the models it's very easily so
the user can build their models by the
reading constructors they can get models
found the 3d graphics or from the image
the waffle language also provided a
reading operations to help to use it to
build the more complex models so like
the user can combine the models and also
can use the reading reading transform to
transform them models so here is a few
other database the water language
support support so we can see there is a
lot of models we have the polyhedral
data and also we have light of more than
200 and not data so the user you that
chemical are interesting chemical models
then we have the chemical data also we
have the learned a lot of and Tommy data
your elevation data and example data so
the wolf a language also our provider
right of sweetie data format light SPL
payo BG so the user can download the
file supported by the Wolfram language
then import to the Mathematica here I
just download one STL file from the my
manufactory
site then I imported to the whorfin
language and get this very nice model
so the water languages also answer we
have a function like a jump to search it
can search through the our 3d models in
the outsider path trees so but this
still in the underdeveloped communities
so here I search the scow and the site
in the e singing words ok then we get to
light a lot of bottles funny thing in
return
here we can click then select button
then we can choose one models all you
can choose the fellow models then we can
click the copy then here we we just on
paste face down below here I just say
model here we can see a lot of the
properties we have the light of mesh
region region and a mesh region so here
I just want to show that the region ok
so this is the lighter scale so so the
whorfin language also on provide a
function the printouts reading each were
or incentive the models to the online
printing service
light i'm materia cheaply so here i just
so want to send the models to the
capture then here we can see the link we
can go to the scope you can see them and
the online preview of the models and
also see their own price order the price
of the hi
so okay so okay let's see there are the
next ok so now we want to use the region
constructor to contract the models okay
this model what we what we do so if we
already have style either 2d imaging
like that so we can use the first we use
the banner eyes the image make the image
black and white then we were to leave
some small components replace with a
background on pixels okay then okay then
we are reverse the colors then used it
call the image mesh okay we were get it
on 2d the models okay now we want to get
a 3d model so what we do we can use the
region product to with a line look at
the really model the thickness of the
model depend on the the length of the
line okay here I just put all the coats
into the one function like the truth
image then I just passed them all yes
here so get to be models like that here
is that I want to get to my own face for
the 3d so I just use the image capture
to capture a image for my for myself you
can capture yourself so yeah so here
let's see what I get
so I find my face from the boundary and
use the image change to get it or my 2d
phrase then here we call the functions
we create okay whatever is like to me
okay so so now we want to create this
kind of models looks very nice the
whooping language already provide a lot
of thoughts we D function like the
resolution parts we D transpose ready to
put this example we will use the
parametric parts meeting so
either either radius one two three so it
has impact so in order to make the
service not to sing so I use the pod
team like the six service so I get on
the graphic sweetie
so now we want to get the models so we
can use the discrete pies graphic to
convert the graphics to the mesh region
okay here is the several graphs we D I
use a lot of props we D poke prod Sweden
and other part function then I just want
to ensure I just reach out and graphics
the models okay here I want crater on
several puzzles so for panel here we can
use the actually used a in every mesh
two very simple here we just create six
4 by 1 4 by 4 matrix okay we just call
it a rematch ok look at a 2d mesh so a
lot of for this one it's like a 1 1 0 0
you know 1 0 then we already see okay
before the part before the example are
see the region part I can make the order
to t2 own 3d right Larry
so here so I want to show how to make
the chest part so mix transport a tree
we also can use the on the the remesh
will create first the create a by a by
will erase then we get the chessboard is
not colorful backs so we try to uncover
the Canada on the light a visitor the
first column should be white black white
black the second is the black white
black white so we want to find out the
position of
the index here is a breakfast so this is
the lighter white black and this is a
lighter and the pattern is here so we
just want to find all the one position
two means or deaths of the of the black
one so then we can use the the highlight
mesh to color the chessboard okay you
get this this one so this is this means
we color the other edge so we just stick
in the black and the color the other
then for the each cue body we first
colored odd is the white then we color
the position here we find the color the
breath also gets nice chessboard okay so
the next several examples I will use the
region region operations so here I just
want to see what is the light imaging
boolean means so here it's a ball and a
cute a cube and here the ball so here is
a really union so it's come by two
bottles here it's a region intersection
here it reads the region difference be
indifferent I traced alighted just
removed the ball from the Q the Q here
either
region difference symmetric difference
actually the Union - the intersection
okay let's see so we want to make this
model so how many on the list or
ellipsoids and here we can see one two
three four it has a floor symmetric
symmetric and flip side and all there is
another way in the center this is mean
we should combine all together
okay so legend so we create a Wyndham
then since the Aleph ID is the symmetric
ones so we can use the transform the
region user location some angles from
the x-axis then we create for them where
we just want to okay Union them then we
can see like a flowers then we want to
make another ellipsoid here we'll put
together with the center here so this is
what we want okay so okay this is a we
want to make Kermit staircases
so for make this one actually we we can
first make the regular one then we can
we can do some we can do some rotation
to the tooter the points then get it on
this one so so for the each step there
is one two three four four points so if
the number of test steps is the end this
is me we should create writer for and
coordinates then we should on the cell
slider for each step we should make to
the sales okay this is one polygon this
is another polygon and that this is the
side of one the right side this is a
left to fight all together okay let's
see okay here we want to make the mix
unconscious first so here we are defined
on some parameter the number of steps is
10 and we want this is a high visit the
width and this is tabs okay okay let's
see here the light the coordinates so
the coolest we see is the light at the
end is step so is the two to at the four
n total so here we just want to use the
ability to see other points to do so
it's actually like that so here's the
like odd-even the index here here is
order the right side is new energy the
light tuned for something so okay now we
want to created a fails to say also we
want to like that the front the mesh we
want to one connected right here the 1 2
4 3 right and and also this one so we
just stop can see ok 1 2 4 3 and this 3
4 6 5 just the one step here actually so
we want to create this is the cells then
we were use the mesh region this is the
conduct this so we just stop okay get it
on here now we get like the front one so
now we want to criticize is here here
conducted the side of my children so we
use the petition to petition odd and
even the one two three four the petition
tutor on the lens of verse 3 and the
upsetting to so let's move Santa sees is
the right side is this metric so it just
plus one then just to join together then
we get the mesh we invite the left side
and the right side okay now we have the
front mesh side mesh now we want to
reunion join them ok now we get the
regular staircases
so okay so we actually want to get it
twisted alone we don't want the regular
so what do we do so do actually we just
later on for the when we create the
coordinates actually for the each step
for four points here we we can use the
location matrix so what do we got here
just so we use the new coordinates
that's it if they still seem okay
now we actually find the chief kid alone
yeah so so you can change the parameter
and change the lighter here that
technologies you can get it know all
kinds of the staircase you want
okay here we want create this change
okay this chain we can see there is
actually two objects there we is the
left right chain another is a pop button
chain so then we just connect together
actually for the chain is ridiculously
the senior there is also some chain here
but it's different with me
similar so let's see I want to create my
own chain so this I I used her magical
region to create the left tallest part
and pallets and other ones and we can
show on okay what do we get for the okay
we get two of them
now we want to together so this is the
number of the change we wanted together
put together so we we went is that the
indexes that are lighter or the number
we use the left/right change and if the
even number we atop button chain
okay this is the lighter created a sweet
okay this is the light at three one two
are together
so okay okay so later on the chaney what
we are sure before okay this is the
models I want to create here so here
actually is a few then there is a lot of
cylinders it's symmetrical one found the
sweet direction
also it's not seated so so what we could
do so we we were checked up Oh
oh I think of something maybe I what
yeah okay so yeah here is the parameter
is the lidar we said then we created a
cuboid then we created a cylinder since
the cylinder is a symmetric so we just
created another truth Linda used
transform the region then locate the
when you're the from the x-axis nothing
is the y-axis okay then we were put
together for the cylinder so we cylinder
then we get this kind of model then we
use the region difference to remove the
gas cylinders to from the Q okay now we
get the like that this kind of thing
model so since this is the model and we
see before it's selected twist it or not
it's nested so we will create we we were
putted all the code the later put other
code into one function the parameter is
depend on s so we will create a sequence
of the models so we let's see
okay now we want to come by them
okay so this is what we we we get the
final models this is the last model I
want to show so if you want to know more
about the more information so actually
we have the light a very nice magnet
page and also have the lighter guide
page you can just check and either go
there then you will see you have like a
lot of information there yeah I think so
yeah so yeah if you interested in the in
the in the in the geometry turn let's
talk about Japan will say pop and
problem solving
yeah yeah right uh-huh
I know you you yeah we were we know and
this is functionality it's very
important to soul we are right now there
isn't no this kind of thing but we we
were try to make it
we have idea we we should make make that
here I know it's you
I'll turn this field
yeah we can we can actually actually we
we should use their reunion
yeah but but the picture right nice
there is not very nice there is some
effect so I just knew this too but I we
were fixed this kind of problems fixed
later yeah thank you